okay ladies gents let's take a look at market structure so first things first
what i'll do is kind of remove everything that isn't structure so we'll remove
sessions
we'll remove liquidity that's already removed we'll remove all the blocks
remove feathery gaps so inside the indicator in general we have structure we
have sessions
we have some customizable features we have the dashboard i'll actually keep
that on there
we have
liquidity order blocks and feathery gaps we have again some customization so we
're
going to be diving into structure so this is what it would look like if you had
only the structure
selected you'll notice there are many highs lows internal highs internal lows
break
changes of character whatever it is but we're going to go through each thing
individually
so you can open up your indicator and the first thing and the most important
thing that i want to
talk about is swing structure so we're going to remove for now internal
structure because to be
quite frank with you internal structure isn't something that i need as an
indicator it's not
something that i really use to be totally honest with you but it is something
that helps other
people as i've noticed and i will still talk about it and at the end i'll also
walk through
my personal settings as i told you but for now we'll just look at swing
structure so we have
show swing structure we have the breaker structure labels the changer character
labels the swing
point labels we'll actually remove the swing point of labels so those are the
higher highs
i don't need them swing level lines we definitely want to see those and unconf
irmed levels those
are also important so if you just have just those things selected what you will
see in here is
your actual trend your actual structure now why this is important first and
foremost
this is built specifically on a set of rules that i have personally developed
myself
over a extended period of time the big question that comes with something like
market structure
is how do you make it objective and repeatable and rule-based which is
objectively repeatable
so many people get market structure wrong such a powerful concept and yet so
few people actually
get it right and the market and the industry is flooded with indicators on
market structure
all i have to do is type market structure and you will see probably thousands
of market
structure indicators so why is ours different why is it not just the same why
don't i just
use somebody else's and the answer to that let's say i turn this indicator on
right here
the answer to that is quite simple if we turn mine off this is the type of
market structure indicators that are out there on the market
indicators that simply put make absolutely no sense whatsoever this indicator
here
makes absolutely no sense whatsoever i mean this is a market structure break
what does that
even mean how is it a market structure break when there is a high and low in
here what constitutes
a marketer break okay well why is this a market structure break why isn't this
a market structure
break then why why is this not a marketer break why is this a marketer break
and this isn't
why is this a marketer break why is this not one why is this not one why is
this not one
these are the swing points it makes no sense and that's what you'll find with
probably every
market structure indicator you'll find out there let's take a look at this
person's
these are the most common ones so now we'll remove yours and we'll look at this
guys
so again another indicator okay break a structure change of character how in
the world is that a
change of character and then that's a change of character and so what you'll
quickly find and
unfortunately we're talking about indicators that thousands of people are using
that is completely
ruining their trading and the main reason for that is because these indicators
are simply built by
non traders who want to sell a product and hey that's fine each to their own
but as i said at
the beginning this is an indicator i've built for myself for my own trading it
was only agreed upon
to share it with you guys when thinking it through i've been using this
indicator before it was
published to you guys because it helps my analysis and so what's different it
actually has rules
in place it doesn't just randomly break highs and lows that give you some
theoretical change of
character that simply make no sense that will just lead you astray you are
better off just flipping
a coin genuinely you would be better off flipping up coin if it lands on tails
my bias is bearish if
it lands on heads my bias is bullish and trading based off of that you'd
probably put more accurate
that's not even an exaggeration like that's genuine because it's just
probabilities
those types of indicators they aren't built by traders for traders they're just
not
no one is using that and if they are they are immensely unprofitable i'll tell
you that for free
and so this indicator is my indicator that's built by myself for myself now why
why have an
indicator why do i decide to use one why don't i just do it myself the time
involved and the
potential for human error and so i developed a very specific set of repeatable
rules that
define whether something is a high a low a break a not break a change of
character etc etc
and those rules have helped me and countless of my students make multiple
hundreds of thousands
of dollars in verified trading profits because the indicator itself isn't the
edge the edge is
the edge the indicator is simply just a way to automate the analysis of the
edge which is primarily
structural based and so every break of structure you see in here every change
of character you see
in here follows a specific set of rules that i personally use that that has
data built into them
that i use that my edge is built upon and this is being years of development so
we'll get into
the kind of nitty-gritty details as you can see in here if you're looking at
this price action
you i mean undoubtedly there are an infinite number of swing points on this
price chart
but not all swing points are the same right why are not all of these levels
highs and all of these levels levels because it follows a specific set of rules
as i've explained
to you that i have tested over years and years of data they're very high degree
of accuracy
and so most swing points are completely inefficient
and the question for you is just if you trust me then you trust me and this
indicator literally
tells you your swing points period if i was to turn this off for example and
you looked at this
naked chart first and foremost where do you start i don't know maybe you look
at this and maybe
you say okay high low high high low low low low low low low low low low low
maybe that would be
your structure right because how else would you define your structure you'd be
looking at all
these different swing points the problem is is none of them are repeatable they
're all just
trying to find some external high and then the doubt comes in because then you
start asking yourself
well what makes this a high and this not a high what makes this a high and this
not a high
what makes this a high and this not a high is this a high is this a high well
isn't this a high what
about this one you don't know because you don't have a repeatable rule in place
that tells you
what is it high and what is it a lot and so you're just left with ultimately
random analysis
that's what it ends up being in the end in the end it just ends up random
analysis
and there are too many times that you get stuck in a situation where you don't
know if something is
actually a break of structure or actually a change of character right for
example let's
just look here if you were to look at this here right this is a high this is a
low we break structure
would you then not conclude that okay well then that's a break of structure
then that's a change
of character so now we're bearish now we're looking for shorts and obviously
that wouldn't play out
because this entire time we were actually bullish
and then you may conclude all this is a low maybe this is the high maybe we're
bullish maybe
you're along in here no we changed character down here so we were actually bear
ish so this is your
entry point this is your area to look for shorts okay well aren't they breaks
of structure no they're
not plain and simply they're not and then we change character and so now the
play is longs
and then we break structure and we change character again and so again in many
cases
maybe you look at this and you go okay swing low swing high change of character
we're bullish
okay we're bullish i'll try to long from here fail long from here fail long
from here
great fail long from here great fail this entire time the play was always
shorts
shorts shorts break of structure shorts again still the high in here price
comes up
these are entry these are entry triggers to go short and then we change
character
no longer is the bias short the bias is no long called change character we pull
back
fair value gap longs pull back longs this becomes the high and again
the rules tell you this is the high not this one now what happens to a lot of
people
a lot of people see this random low in here and they define it as they change a
character
so what would you be doing well simply put that's a change of character i'm
going to short
the market fail short the market fail when this entire time the real move was
after we break
structure into fair value up we're longing from here that's how you get caught
on the wrong side
of the market and then many people would be looking at the same thing again let
's say price
pushes up to the highs right we're bullish so i should long in here fail
longing here fail
the change of character comes here the shorts are here
we break structure shorts are here we break structure shorts are here we break
structure
yes you would try and short and you would lose which is completely a part of
the game
obviously that is the whole point of an edge and edge is nothing more than a
statistical
expectancy over a period of time period but the only way you can develop an
edge and statistical
expectancy is by having concrete rules that give you expectancy expectancy can
only be created out
of predictability something must be predictable for it to be long-term
profitable if it's random
random highs random lows no logic you can't ever create expectancy you will
just get literally
random sheer random results and so we change character the pullback is the long
we break
structure the pullbacks let's go along we break structure the pullbacks let's
go along
we break structure which leads us up to where we are right now which is a
pretty large range and
sometimes it happens this is the low we wick the low not a change of character
we wick the low
and it's very simple some people would look at this they'd see that it wicks
the lows down here
and they would put it as a change of character right but that's pattern
recognition that's not
logic at all if something wicks below a level it simply means that price did
not accept lower
prices it's plain and simple it's just it's just logic it's common sense if i'm
the only buyer in
the market and you're the only seller in the market and i simply do not accept
to buy at your price
i either cannot buy or you cannot sell period if price does not accept lower
than a level right
price does not accept lower it's not going to go lower and you can see in here
we reach the level
we wick below failed we'll try again failed we'll try again failed we'll try
again failed
how could you categorize that as a change and try to then short the market
wrong wrong wrong right price was always expected to trade higher from the back
of this
that's why a wick should never be a breakup structure or change of character
because a wick is literal
literally implying a failed acceptance and so that structure structure is
simply the external
swing points of price coded on specific set of rules that will tell you where
is a low where
is a high and what the bias is this little thing in here tells you gives you
the idea of it on
more per time frames so you can see here the h4 is bearish the m15 is bullish
the m1 is bearish
now maybe you don't use a 15 minute time frame maybe use a 30 minute time frame
doesn't change anything maybe use a one hour time frame doesn't change anything
right it's the same rules on different time frames consistency you can see in
here in the hourly
time frame you can see break structure change character change character change
character
now this is a textbook manipulation reversal model when price barely breaks and
then barely
breaks and then rallies through and then rallies through this is an indication
of
liquidation the good thing about this is the that's why we use multiple time
frame analysis
because again plain and simple let's say we were to we change character in here
right so now we
bearish there's your bearish waterblock for example and we absolutely rally
straight through price
do you think there is any way to get short in this move unless you're a fool of
course there
isn't there's no lower time frame confirmation price run straight through it
and then we change
character now we're bullish do you think there is any way on a lower time frame
for you to get along
in this area now of course price just run straight through it that's the
important of multi time frame
analysis so we might be bearish on the one hour and when price gets to a level
we drop to a lower
time frame to look for structure on that time frame to tell us that yes price
does accept this
and now we will continue lower and so when we just run through and run through
you won't see it now
take this for example we change character we come back up what happens here
acceptance price reaches
a level right bearish we reach a level we begin accepting the price we shift as
you can see the
highs to the lows the entry is right here and we continue to the low and so
that's all that is
this is always the same thing again here you can see some people maybe look at
okay price
shift bearish here we got stopped out okay no problem price is now shifted
bullish right we got
in oh great it worked we're bullish again oh wait no now we're bearish oh wait
now we're bullish
again you missed all the moves the real move was here this was the high these
are your longs
right you probably got out of here you'd wait after this reversal you don't
then try and change
anything price breaks we're bullish you still go long in here this just becomes
a liquidation
this is your move out these are your levels and you're gone because price was
always bullish
and then this is a textbook reversal we've been bullish for a very long period
of time
when price gets into price goes from expansion which is what this is to
contraction which usually
looks something like this typical reversal indication and then we get the sell
now
which is usually a lot more smoother simply again we break structure in here
sell opportunities price comes back what do we get acceptance
confirmation acceptance confirmation pull back and go to target
so that's what you'll find what this structure indicator will do for you
it will basically give you your bias and realistically how i use it it's i
trade in direction of the
bias 98 percent of the time if structure is bullish like this we have a break
of structure
we have a low down here i'm trying to be a buyer after we get some type of
lower time frame
confirmation and i just want to play the bullish continuation that i know
are probable to continue in fact let's just take a look at this let's go to the
one hour time frame
all right let's map out let's say 10 levels so what we're seeing here is we
have a high
to a low and we have a right change of character sorry so now we're bullish
so the first one from high to low gets a continuation so we're bullish and we
continue
there's one for pro trend we break structure we pull back and we continue
there's another one pro trend right we pull back we get a break of structure in
the direction of
the trend pro trend then we get a change of character and we don't follow
through
then we get another change of character we don't follow through
so that's two in favor for price takes a level and doesn't continue however
this is where you must be contextually aware in understanding what's happening
here
when price runs through aggressively like this and like this there was no way
you was ever
going to trade in direction of that change of character price changed character
to bearish
you was never going to be able to gain alongs there in shorts price just would
not give you
an opportunity so those are the incidences where you will find reversals no
problem
we change character with bearish does price continue yes this is just the most
recent price
action okay we're bearish do we pull back and continue yes we pull back and
continue okay
another one now we're bearish do we pull back and continue no we change
character
and by the way even still the change of character itself is the reversal period
we change character we become bullish do we pull back do we continue yes
so it's just probabilities we can see here there are a total of nine instances
where
structure was broken six out of nine which is more than 60 percent around 63 66
percent
of the time after price broke structure in a certain direction it continued in
that direction
giving you potential tradable setups and even the situations where it didn't
play out
still untradeable situations that's what this market structure indicator is
here to do for you
that's its job and when you understand the statistical probability you
understand that
there's a 70 percent chance that we will probably get a continuation or that
price will probably
shift from here well now that's something that you can build a trader model of
that's something that you can build expectancy of because it's the same set of
rules the same
principles that are re-occurring not random left to chance models that you
choose a high
and you choose a low you're not randomly choosing a high and randomly choosing
a low
if you were to do something like that it would look something more along the
lines of this
so you would choose a low cool you would choose a high cool so we break the low
and we come up with
a high and then we continue and then for example after that we would come put
in a low in here
we would put in a low in here we would put in a high in here these are just
random highs and lows
and then price would break the highs give you a reversal break the lows give
you a reversal
break the highs then you'd have a new high a new low we'd break the highs we'd
break the lows
you'd have a new high and new low you'd break the lows so you won't be able to
trade the highs
this is all you could do just to identify the swings far less accurate not
repeatable
so it's completely left down to random chance and everything just becomes messy
and most of these
even these micro moves they're untradable for the most part because there's not
enough substance
in their distances or their pullbacks and so that's the swing structure that's
predominantly
what's important in this structure indicator you can also use the internal and
this will
basically show you the internal structure and like i said this isn't something
that i personally
keep toggled i'll be honest with you but for some people it's you know valuable
and so if we were for its load
you can see something in here for example like we have a it's still based on
repeatable principles
as well we have a low any high everything inside is internal so we put in a low
we put any high
we get an internal break of structure so bearish internally until we eventually
reach the target
but we're still bullish so we still say bullish then we have an internal change
of character
and so for some people maybe that's their confirmation in an external price leg
that you're
bullish you wait for internal price movement i prefer lower time frame
confirmation as opposed
to internal but hey whatever kind of floats your boat you know i added it in
there because
it's still something that people find valuable it's still something that can
help you to be honest
with you but to be frank not something that i personally use but play around
with it see if
it's something that you like so now we'll look at sessions